[Applause]
that's why
what's interesting about that
I don't think that was in reaction to
anything that happened with the official
on that offensive rebound Curry being
guarded by Chalmers Curry lost him
[Applause]
because he threw his mouthpiece in a
direction after he scores his lip here
no Falco you see here he throws his
mouth yeah that's an automatic injection
through his mouthpiece at Scott wall
that is an automatic injection and Curry
will be writing a big check well then
Kevin Durant
thank you
that's Tristan Thompson able to get that
deflected rebound
[Applause]
Ed for the game
and it hit a fan Mike
Steph Curry
apologizes to the fans he thought he got
all ball
and then got in front of James
and that was it was that second contact
that they called
we rarely see Curry lose it like that